there is something deeply unsettling
about an old house at night what is
beautiful if a bit worse for wear during
the day can take on a sinister cast once
the sun goes down the moan of the wind
outside the creek of the floorboards the
scraping of a branch against a window
maybe one of these sounds jolts you
awake in the dead of night eyes opening
to a room full of shadows turn twisted
and eerie in the darkness of course it's
probably nothing supernatural just an
old house settling mixed with your own
paranoia but sometimes every so often it
is something more sometimes you're not
as alone in an old house as you think
you are that's certainly the case if you
ever find yourself staying in scp-2696
also known as the haunted victorian
mansion of dark peak in 1869 wealthy and
renowned industrialist and scholar of
the occult henry percival recyth built a
stately home known as rosith hall to
house him his wife clara and any
children they might have in the future
it was constructed to provide henry with
ample space to conduct his arcane
research clara with a beautiful sitting
room and a flower garden to tend and
their future children with lots of space
to play and run around as they grew
after an uneventful year in the house
clara gave birth to two baby boys named
edgar and miles for a time the family
was happy there unfortunately this
happiness was to be short-lived as the
grim specter of death soon began to loom
over russith hall in january of 1873
clara was overcome with a sudden fever
and died in her bed this loss pushed the
already eccentric henry over the edge
and he began making strange changes to
the house's interior structure he added
hallways that led to dead ends strangely
angled floors and twisting corners
turning a once comfortable and lived-in
home into something unrecognizable in
august of that same year henry's
children edgar and miles also suddenly
passed away leaving henry alone at his
estate as he continued his descent into
madness he kept modifying the house
expanding from the mansion's library and
tower to the rest of the building's
rooms henry's days were spent
supervising the construction around the
house
refusing to let the workers carry on
without his strict oversight worried
that otherwise his vision would be
corrupted his nights were spent
sleepless as he worked away in the tower
and in the nursery on the second floor
no one was permitted to witness his work
during the night but his household staff
complained of strange sounds flashing
lights and strange whispers many were so
unsettled by these sounds and mr
rossite's erratic behavior that they
quit their jobs without notice a wise
choice given the circumstances as his
staff dwindled so too did henry russet's
already fragile grip on reality his
request for materials became more and
more imposing he demanded 200 kilograms
of ground stone from isle of angle sea
in wales and 37 meters of pipes made
from an amalgam of mercury and copper
among other unconventional materials but
rothschi still had money to burn and no
family to spend it on anymore so his
every strange request was accommodated
for a time anyway in june of 1876
exhausted and unsettled by the long
hours of work the ever increasingly
strange projects and the unusual
supernatural phenomena around the house
the remainder of ross ice workers quit
he then fired all of his household staff
with the exception of his loyal
housekeeper and resumed his work in
solitude though the specifics of just
what mr ruthsife was trying to achieve
would likely have gone to the grave with
him some of his diary entries were
recovered from the house and they
provide a peek into his motives and
nature of the mansion's anomalous
activity after the death of his wife and
children he became obsessed with the
concept of the mind-made body the notion
that having a memory so strong that if
given the proper energetic conditions it
could take on corporeal form his theory
was if a memory is engraved permanently
in the mind it could then take on a
permanent physical and energetic
manifestation he began to experiment
with this concept determined to bring
back a form of his wife and children by
any means necessary a noble pursuit that
paved the way for madness it is during
this process that he began to remodel
the house in order to provide the ideal
energetic conditions for his memories to
be made material eventually his notes
devolved into nonsense and the pages
were covered with geometric equations
and blood his final entry reads the
children still speak in her voice i fear
i might be going mad it is true that he
might have been losing his grip on
sanity towards the end of his
experiments but his work undeniably
filled the house with something it was
not long before reports of strange
sights and sounds around the russith
home reached the ears of those trained
to investigate such matters the house
and its anomalous nature were initially
discovered by jintinder jaishankar an
occultist and investigator employed by
the royal foundation for the secure
containment of the paranormal or rfscp
he wrote the first official report on
the house in 1876
after investigating multiple rumors of
ghostly sightings around the house he
and his team a married pair of ghost
hunters named the bartons arrived at the
rossite home with a sense of
apprehension they were ushered through
the door by a housekeeper who made the
eerie promise that henry russith would
be with them shortly when the master of
the house came to greet them the
investigative team was shocked by his
appearance he was gaunt almost skeletal
with a dark set eyes bleary from
entirely too long without sleep he
looked as if he had aged a hundred years
in the few years since his wife's death
the team stayed the night in the house
experiencing a restless and nightmare
adult sleep until 2 30 am when the
investigative work was to begin they
descended down to the main hall of the
house where a large black door was all
that stood between them and the unknown
it opened with a bone-deep groan as if
to warn them not to enter but still they
stepped inside once they crossed the
threshold they were greeted with odd
angles a garish array of colors and
materials and bewilderingly high
ceilings all to mr ross scythe's very
demanding specifications of course he
spared no expense in making his
nonsensical nightmare house an
unsettling reality the bartons presented
dowsing rods which they used to measure
spiritual activity in the room at first
nothing happened but soon the dowsing
rods began to spark viciously and a
sudden gust of wind blew out all the
candles in the room there was nothing
but darkness and the sudden sense of a
heavy presence among them the bartons
dropped to the floor with mrs barton
leaking blood from her mouth and dr
barton convulsing violently the presence
grew stronger and though it did not
speak it was unmistakable who it was it
was the deceased clara rossith
jaishankar fled the manor dragging his
unconscious companions out as fast as he
could once safely away from the mansion
he immediately contacted the rfs cp well
as quickly as one can when communicating
by telegram a second team was sent to
investigate the house in the following
days but when they arrived henry russith
could not be found there was no sign of
a struggle no body he simply
vanished he was never seen again
the scp foundation has an official
record of two separate incorporeal
entities that dwell within the walls of
scp-2696
the first
scp-2696-1 appears to be the ghost or
memory energetic signature whatever you
wish to call it of clara rossais the
apparition is the one that jintinder
jaikansha and the bartons encountered
she is translucent and intangible and
most frequently appears in the form of
clara as a young mother at the pinnacle
of her good health she has also
occasionally taken on several inhuman
forms including a wilting plumeria bush
and a disturbing column of bone muscle
and flesh exposure to the clara entity
has a pronounced negative effect on
anyone who comes near her people that
come within several feet of
scp-2696 have reported mild visual and
auditory hallucinations such as creeping
shadows and whispering voices chanting
in foreign languages there have also
been reports of amnesia fainting
seizures bleeding from the nose mouth
and ears and in the most severe cases
disassociative episodes that result in
complete losses of identity many of
these physical side effects are thought
to be the result of the massive amounts
of radiation that have been measured
being given off by the entity the second
entity in the house known as scp-2696-2
is actually two entities that always
seem to come as a pair known as 2a and
2b these are the skeletons of miles and
edgar rossith the deceased children of
clara and henry they're located inside
of the nursery which is inaccessible to
outsiders with the door that seems able
to seal itself shut at will and keep
researchers out the two skeletons are
largely inactive remaining on the floor
of the nursery in the fetal position at
nearly all times they only become active
during periods of extreme activity from
the clara entity when clara is
especially active and attempting to
leave her usual domain in the house's
tower the skeletons have been reported
to wrestle and play with each other
dance around the room or stand at the
door to the nursery appearing to be
waiting for something one notable
occasion though on june 12 1990 both
instances of
scp-2696-2 were able to actually leave
the nursery and travel elsewhere in the
house a series of massive lightning
strikes raised the energy levels in the
house and clara's radiation levels
suddenly spiked significantly surge
protectors placed in the house failed
and clara became more active than usual
transforming into a swirling dark mass
that emitted an ear splitting shriek the
front door of the mansion slammed itself
shut and refused to open trapping the
research team who were present at the
time they were only able to exit after
scp-2696-2a
and 2b were spotted leaving the nursery
hand in hand they approached clara and
opened their arms to her pacified
perhaps by some distant echo of a
mother's love the entity quieted and the
foundation team was finally able to
leave it is still unknown how 2a and 2b
were able to leave the nursery but there
have not been any incidences of this
level since currently the dark peak
mansion remains standing and is largely
untouched from how its creator left it
the scp foundation maintains a strict
perimeter of one square kilometer around
the house and no civilians are permitted
to cross it not only is the building
restricted for civilians most scp
personnel are also forbidden from
entering the house some of the only ones
who are allowed inside are a special
class of scp foundation personnel
experimental containment research group
or ecrg and mtf theta 77 nicknamed who
you gonna call given what was learned in
the 1990 activation event it is apparent
that the containment procedures have a
rate of failure that does not adequately
contain
scp-2696-1 and according to the
containment file there is a 47 chance of
clara breaching containment completely
by 2030. catherine stedman once wrote
houses aren't haunted people are henry
russith was so haunted by the loss of
his beloved wife and children that he
could not stand to live in his big empty
house all alone henry russeth may be
long gone but his attempts to grasp at
that which was long gone before him have
forever changed the house he built his
grief his pain his energy filled the
house with echoes of his loved ones and
as pain often does when left untreated
it began to fester and turn foul dr
henry russeth was a deeply haunted man
and now his haunted house is all that
remains of him now go check out
scp-1730 what happened to site 13 the
full story compilation and
scp-1337 the hitchhiker for more
anomalies that'll chill you to the bone